mientras francia se prepara para un
relajamiento significativo de las
restricciones la vacunación en el país
ha alcanzado un objetivo clave
el presidente macrón se dirigió a
twitter para anunciar que 20 millones de
personas es decir alrededor del 30 por
ciento de la población han recibido ya
una primera dosis la noticia llega días
antes de la reapertura de las terrazas
museos y comercios no esenciales y
cuando las autoridades sanitarias
reportan una nueva desaceleración del
número de casos más de 4000 personas
todavía están siendo tratadas en un cis
pero ese número está muy por debajo del
pico de seis mil en marzo llamado pulmón
de sant fost obviamente este es un
momento muy importante para todo el país
porque abre y refuerza las perspectivas
de finalizar la crisis de texis expertos
afirman que aquellos que estén
totalmente vacunados deberían permanecer
inmunes durante al menos ocho meses
decimos que ocho meses porque esta es la
duración de los estudios más largos que
se han llevado a cabo eso no quiere
decir que la inmunidad no vaya a durar
más simplemente quiere decir que no
tenemos estudios más allá de eso
estudios sugieren que aquellos que se
contagian tras ser vacunados tienen
menos posibilidades de contagiar a otros
cuando estás vacunado tienes anticuerpos
que te protegen de contraer una
enfermedad fuerte y también de un nivel
alto de replicación viral boston el
gobierno espera haber inoculado 30
millones de primeras dosis para mitad de
junio para esa fecha los restaurantes
podrán atender clientes en interiores y
los gimnasios estarán abiertos para
finales de junio el actual toque de
queda deberá retirarse junto con la
mayoría de las medidas de cuarentena aún
en vigor